dany dubé bonsoir bonsoir pt qu'est ce
qui explique les succès du canadien
quels sont les facteurs dany qui
explique ça et si bien que la grande
confiance du canadien son expérience la
rigueur de son jeu défensif ça ces trois
éléments essentiels pour avoir des
discussions série évidemment le fait que
le gardien numéro un de l'équipe adverse
est blessé c'est impressionnant pour un
jeune gardien comme les d'backs de se
dire à tous les soirs faut que je sois
meilleur quelqu'un qui vient de gagner
médaille d'or aux olympiques
c'est pas évident même si prince a connu
un match plus faibles et là le reste
l'équipe à compenser exactement ce qu'on
voyait pas nécessairement ans et aurait
dû d'affaires et et de l'aveu même des
déjà de l'organisation de l'entourage du
lightning ils étaient déçus de leur
équipe de ne pas avoir tiré avantage
série profite enfin d'où des lacunes
mais ils ont dû match ordinaire de carey
price en se disant ils pourront pas être
comme ça deux matchs de suite et il
avait tout à fait michel therrien
rappelle souvent et répète souvent cette
marotte indien on joue un match à la fin
on est dans le présent c'est plus qu'une
maroc annonce d'importance et c'est
essentiel c'est une sorte de course à
pied quand on fait des longues distances
non pas pour deux heures de course 1h30
faut jamais penser à la longueur
sinon ils tous on met pas le port et
l'aéroport ni savoir-faire match on
pense au premier kilomètre au deuxième
mais est institué alors le match de
hockey en séries c'est exactement cela
c'est le concept qu'il faut respecter
faux papas ans au prochain match faut
aller s'asseoir sur le banc prendre une
gorgée d'autres pensées à sa prochaine
présence parce qu'il faut vivre en
présence les choses changent tellement
rapidement
il ya tellement de facteurs qui viennent
ce qui peut faire basculer une série
d'un côté ou de l'autre évidemment mais
elle nous donne
de ce côté motivateur d'une série
éliminatoire on voit des gosses qui
jouent beaucoup mieux qu'ils ont jamais
joué pendant la saison c'est donc c'est
réel oui c'est réel c'est à la fois
complexe et très simples expliqué il ya
deux facteurs qui permettent à des joies
de se mettre en valeur à séries
d'après-saison le premier c'est que tes
joueurs clés doivent être bon parce que
plus tu es joueurs clés sont bons plus
tu déstabilise la défensive adverse plus
tu forces adversaire à considérer donc
ça fait de la place pour nous donc il ya
d'autres joueurs qui seront en vo -
s'occuper d'eux parce qu'on mène au
meilleur joueur du mondial bourthes
prenons un exemple the boer l'oeil enfin
il a allumé il ya qui t'arrive bourque
ne pourrait pas faire ce que pacioretty
fait l'absence de pacioretty empêcherait
boucle de faire ce qu'il a fait parce
que bourque et bénéficie d'un peu d'un
peu plus de laxisme en défensive parce
que tout le monde surveille le numéro 67
pacioretty sa meilleure équipe avec
vania qu'est donc pas mais on surveille
cela il ya de la place pour nous et il
s'assied première depuis le deuxième si
vous me permettez qui est très important
c'est l'espèce de combativité les joies
qui sont plus linéaires qui ont un jeu
plus linéaire qui sont beaucoup plus
costaud qui travaillent plus dans les
îles deviennent extrêmement efficace
parce que le jeu se resserre de façon
drastique en séries d'après saison tu
dis que le jeu se resserre mais je suis
loin d'être un expert j'ai l'impression
que le canadien sort mieux de saison oui
pourquoi parce que le lightning
actuellement a pas réussi à établir sa
possession de rondelle dans le
territoire du canadien
pour deux raisons les chip qui a vendu
canadiens en poche lightning d'attaquer
le canadien avec autorité avec des
surnoms donc c'est facile pour canadien
défendre donc comme ils défendent
facilement il contre attaque beaucoup
plus aisément parce que
l'autre équipe est déstabilisée et ça
vient du fait que on accorde quelque
chose à l'adversaire on leur donne la
passe et loignon leur donne un joueur
qui est tout seul compte deux défenseurs
et ce jour là très rarement va réussir à
déjouer le gardien du niveau de cryptage
et dany tu n'as pas parler de ce facteur
on écoute
même si bourque savais pas qu il l a
compris qu'elle était importante au
québec il ya les gens qui étaient
évidemment au centre bell ont eu des
frissons à la maison dans une des
prisons les joueurs aussi forcément
absolument puis c'est s'est documenté
les équipes qui croit alors chanteurs
chanteuses des nationale joue mieux je
joue mieux dans les scieries d'ailleurs
que tu imites s'est documenté oui avec
les flyers de philadelphie les voix
voulez la voir d'ailleurs à quand elle
est décédée hier même renault vainqueur
ce soir c'est extraordinaire ok il faut
que je te laisse aller mon terminal à
quel moment les montréalais auront droit
de dire que ça sent vraiment la cour
deuxième rang parce qu'ils auront à
battre les bruins de boston
je pense que les blues vont gagner
contre contre les red wings de detroit
ils sont meilleurs que nous aux
meilleures formations
tous les experts se sont prononcés pour
dire que dans l'est
l'équipe à battre c'est les cld des
blouses à volants mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est que le canadien numéro du bois
d'enghien tubize toujours un plaisir
chaque convoi se reparler merci mon
match soit merci salut